la décision a été rendue le 7 décembre
dernier le tribunal judiciaire de tours
a ordonné le retrait d'un compteur linky
installé chez une tourangelle qui
souffre d' électrosensibilité la fin
d'un combat débuté en octobre 2018 dès
la pose du compteur électrique
on en parle ce soir avec l'un des
protagonistes de cette histoire
marc meurin bonsoir bonsoir mêmes vous
êtes donc avocat touré régulièrement
nous vous recevons pour nous expliquer
des points de droit ce soir on revient
avec vous sur cette affaire de compteurs
linky que vous avez plaidé et gagner
alors quels sont les arguments qui ont
fait mouche et qui ont convaincu le
tribunal
alors quand la requérante et me voir là
on va l'appeler geneviève elle m'a dit
je suis persuadé que depuis
l'installation de mon compteur linky ça
me cause des problèmes de santé
je vais expliquer qu'il fallait monter
un dossier et qu'il serait bien que l'on
ait des éléments médicaux pour établir
un préjudice et un lien de causalité
entre c'est ce qu'elle ressentait des
malaises des vomissements des choses
comme ça et l'installation de son
compteur linky
elle a donc monté un dossier médical et
trois médecins ont eu un avis à peu près
identiques dont le docteur rebelles
pomme qui est un spécialiste de
l'électro sensibilité donc il a été
établi que c'était une personnes
électrosensibles ça c'était la première
chose
et deuxièmement elle est atteinte d'une
pathologie grave est une maladie auto
immune au niveau de la thyroïde et on a
constaté médicalement qu'en 2017 2018
son état s'est stabilisé et que depuis
l'installation de ce compteur cette
femme qui à 73 ans a vécu une
aggravation de son état de santé
donc maintenant sur le compte du
compteur alors qu'adil juge le lien de
causalité n'est pas établie il existe un
principe constitutionnel ce principe
constitutionnel c'est le principe de
précaution
il y a des études qui indique que les
champs électromagnétiques parce qu'il
faut savoir que ces compteurs émettent
des champs électromagnétiques
il y adeux ce qu'on appelle des ping
toutes les 3 à 4 minutes c'est à dire
que ce n'est pas permanent mais c'est
quasiment tout le temps donc on a établi
qu'au niveau du compteur mais aussi au
niveau des câbles il y avait des champs
électromagnétiques qui émettait des
ondes et les études démontrent que ces
champs électromagnétiques peuvent être
cancérigènes donc le juge d'orange eau
en référé a dit il faut appliquer le
principe de précaution et en conséquence
alors il y avait deux solutions soit on
mettait un filtre ou un blindage
certaines décisions avait préconisé
l'installation d'un filtre ou d'un
blindage qui coûte à peu près 400 euros
le juge de tours est allé au delà et à
dinan enlèvement parce que à partir du
moment où les ondes électromagnétiques
n'existe pas uniquement au niveau du
compteur on change le compteur et on
remet un conteur ancien kiné mais rien
est ce que ça peut faire jurisprudence
cette décision alors serez-vous hélène
je pourrais pas faire enlever votre
compteur linky vous m'avez l'air tout à
fait en bonne santé
alors il faut qu'il y ait quand même des
éléments médicaux
il faut qu'on soit en présence d'une
personne qui soit électrosensibles donc
on est dans des cas tout à fait
spécifique avec des conditions médicales
qui doivent être démontrée est ce que la
société n'ait liste peut encore faire
appel à ce que le délai court toujours
alors il faut savoir que c'est une
décision qui a été rendue par le juge du
référé alors le juge du référé le juge
de l'urgence aussi le juge de l'évidence
c'est pour ça qu'il a pris une décision
où il a tranché dans le vif
et le juge tourangeau a appliqué une
astreinte c'est à dire que les aînés 10
à un délai pour enlever le compteur et
s'il n'en lève pas ce conteur et bien il
y aura une astreinte de 500 euros par
jour de retard
alors même s'ils font appel leur appel
n'est pas suspensif c'est à dire qu'en
pratique ils doivent exécuter cette
décision de justice est ce que là le
compteur a été enlevé pour l'instant le
compteur n'a pas été encore enlever
puisque nous sommes dans l'attenté d'une
décision signée par le juge que nous
allons signifié par voie d'huissier à la
société inédit ce pour faire courir le
délai